on a beach near calais police find an
outboard motor possibly abandoned by
people smugglers but there's also a real
struggle to prevent migrants from
reaching these beaches in the first
place
the french border police has stepped up
its checks on the frontier with belgium
up to 60 of migrants looking to cross
the channel enter france across this
border
the man in charge of trying to stop that
is keen to point out their successes
france has stepped up policing actions
but some of the tactics seem
self-defeating
this patch of wasteland here in dunkirk
illustrates what the french police are
up against just over a week ago up to
1500 migrants were camped out here on
this patch of ground then in a dawn raid
french police swooped and cleared the
site leaving just the detritus you see
here
but the migrants decamped and set up a
new base here on these disused railway
tracks just a mile up the road
here we meet an iraqi kurd sanger ahmed
he previously lived in britain for four
years and is now trying to get back he
says the police have cracked down on the
migrants
as i hear from the uk government giving
more
spending more more investment and giving
a given to the
french french authorities to make the
border secure and secure so so that's
why police taking our tents
and sleeping base from one and
displacing
us from one place to another every day
france is deploying more police on its
border with belgium but there's so much
money to be made in trafficking that
people will continue to take their
chances buy land as well as sea
stephen murphy's sky news on the french
belgium border